[Music]
let's go out to Phoenix Arizona and talk
to Megan hey Megan what's
happening good morning sir how are you
good morning to you I'm doing great
what's up
good well I was wondering if you can
give me some tips or tricks to
successfully grieve a life that I
thought I would
have and accept why don't you have it
things
are uh I well let me say this have it
what's the life you you you thought you
would have right
now I I expected that I
would get married
and around I'll be honest I had it laid
out I just kind of you know you take for
granted I guess certain things and I
just assumed that by 25 26 I would get
married have the wedding day and I would
have two or three kids between 27 and
32 and that's what I that's what I saw
new incomes minimal
debt family
vacations and life just went a whole lot
of Direction what
happened where'd it go well I
it's
I what I tried to I did not meet anybody
um that felt right for a long time and
then I decided at 32 33 I was like okay
well I'll just do it myself and so I
lost 50 pounds to up my chances and I
put money away and I up hold on up your
chances for what artificial insemination
ah okay so take care of yourself I
thought you were like I'm getting rid of
these dating apps but you're talking
about like no I'm going to just become a
mom on my own okay all right all right
no I I decided you know well I can do
this myself and so I looked into
artificial insemination and I was like
okay I'm definitely going to need money
and I will have better chance of success
if I lose some weight um I did three
rounds and two of them didn't take one
did but I lost
it which was disappointing
hey hold on hold on it wasn't
disappointing that's
devastating right yeah was that was
rough yeah let's don't just be like oh
well like that that's
brutal so lots of money lots of time
lots of
investment and then
okay so then
I I met I met my
man I met him
and it was that
cheesy weird feeling where it was it was
the fireworks but it was also that sense
of calm it was there you are it was just
home it was
peace
and I thought there's my picture now it
here he
is
and over the course of several months I
ended up finding that he actually
is Believe It or Not in
prison
and he was he was wrongfully convicted
of child molestation and I know how that
sounds believe
me you think it I uh I thought it too
um and I mean
we have been fighting it
and and here we are six years later and
he's lost hope a few times and I've lost
hope a few
times and is just like you look up one
day and I'm like I'm 38
now and it's just like wow this
is definitely a different picture than I
would have ever guessed for
myself
let's have it let's have it I know it's
coming I mean there's nothing no there's
nothing coming I mean
um I'm going to put aside The Single
part because that's hard that's a mess
especially these days okay especially if
you think back to 10 years ago when all
these or all of the world's problems
were going to be solved through dating
apps and all that kind of that that
world right which is right when you're
doing all this um that world's a mess so
I'm not going to I'm not going to Har on
that but I guess the thing I want you to
to Really
internalize is this is the life you've
repeatedly chosen on a regular basis and
agree I it's not I don't happen to you
does that make
sense yeah and it's I I don't I don't
regret my decisions to be with him I
think it's more of like
I
I just I I feel like I always made the
right choices in life you know I always
went to school I had you know the
perfect credit score I had my M's by 30
I took care of everybody I juggled work
in school and took care of grandparents
and parents like I made all the right
decisions and so then I there's this
child in me that wants to throw a
tantrum and be like this isn't fair I I
made all the right choices I did all the
right things here's here's what you did
here's what you did you got the shiniest
pair of tap shoes and the coolest hat
and the nicest
cane and you've been singing and dancing
for everybody for 38
years and so you did all the right
things but all those things were things
that other people told you were going to
make you valuable andw worthy here's how
I know that you don't care a lot about
your your graduate degree people I know
who
are
um like you hear me talk a lot about
like we put all the marketing materials
I got two phds I don't never talk about
my Master's Degree you know why because
it was a high five that the school gave
me in route to something deeply
important to me which was learning this
material but there was a season when I
just wanted to get a masters because
people told me that would make me more
valuable in the marketplace
yeah I I happened to work for a
university and so I got it for free it
was like my mom said well it's a free
Masters I would tell every friend I have
I would tell him that I continu it I'll
tell everybody in the planet if you work
at a university and they get free
graduate degrees of course take
one the challenge is you thought it was
going to feel
differently and that it was going to be
the key that unlocked the portal to not
like more money or not more whatever it
was going to solve
you I'm gonna take care of grandma I'm
gonna take care of Mom and Dad I'm gonna
go do the next right thing I'm G to make
sure I don't borrow a lot of money I'm
going to have all these things were
supposed to be what made you feel still
inside and they
didn't and my fear as you're waking up
at 38 realizing you've been and even the
last six years I'm not going to fight
you on whether I think this your
boyfriend's guilty or
not but for six years you've been
fighting somebody else's
fight and my fear is youve woke up at 38
realizing you made a bunch of choices
every day for your whole life and you
never bothered to ask Megan what do you
want to
do I think what I I well I knew what I
wanted I
wanted a wedding day where my mom could
see me in a dress and my friends and
family around I wanted the relationship
with my child like my mom had with her
mom and I have with
mine I get that
but and that's gut-wrenching I'm
sorry and I'll tell you now that I've
learned since being in this being in
this mess it's like so eye opening you
know you just don't know anything about
the justice system or the prison system
and you get into it and you're just like
what in the world yeah it's wild it's
hard not to just to get caught up in it
because I
mean it's just here's here's my we
thought it would be different we when
you know we thought that you know I we
got a postconviction lawyer and he was
super experienced and found a dozen
errors some of which were egregious and
constitutional and the court of appeals
agreed like if this is true we're due
remedy and we were like okay
we're this is going to be
over and it's
just hey Megan I mean obviously with all
of it it's just you are over 38 years
you have mastered the art of taking a
left of saying look over
here because looking deep inside the
mirror hurts doesn't it it was supposed
to be
different it was supposed to be
different the only way I can tell
you to I can give you a couple of tips
and tricks on grieving
okay um most importantly I want you to
um pick up a book by David Kessler
called finding meaning it's the single
best book on Grief ever written
okay and there's some important um
things in there and whether you're
grieving the loss of a life that you
wanted or whether you're grieving
somebody's passed away in your life or
you've lost a Lov whatever and you've
had a lot of loss in your
life and I can give you a couple of
quick things that you can that you know
just for you and the audience
here I'm me tell you you're going to
have to sit down and own
this for your body to metabolize
it and you're so quick to not feel that
hurt to move on to the next and to the
next to the next to the
next even just in this
conversation I want you to write 26y old
Megan a letter say dear
Megan I'm
sorry and this might sound cheesy
um but it might be a matter of you
sitting on the floor and literally
hugging
yourself but I want you to Envision
yourself hugging that 26y old girl and
saying hey this picture that you have
it's going to be
different yeah I never had time
to no let's I want to change your
language okay you've chosen not to have
time I want to begin to own these things
as
choices because otherwise it feels like
the whole world is happening to us all
the
time and you did take some pretty bold
action I'm going to go go the um
artificial insemination route it didn't
work very expensive you had lots of
dreams you dreamed about holding that
baby you probably started going through
names you went down that rabbit hole and
that's painful but even in this call you
avoided it you're like yeah that kind of
was crummy no dude you got to sit in
that for a
minute feels like a loss you had a name
right oh I had a few yeah and I had I
had friends that were like giving baby
stuff already of course they were cuz
they were all in this with you
yeah maybe write a letter to that little
baby say I would have loved to been
holding you right
now I'm sorry we didn't get to me suck
John I know but this sucks too right
yeah
yes it's not a slap in the face but this
is a slow being held right underwater
and you can see the light you can barely
almost breathe but you just
can't the last thing I would tell you to
do is to get and you may have heard me
say this early on in the show I used to
say this a lot but I want you to get a
cender block of some sort I want you to
go to Lowe's or Home Depot get a cender
block and get some duct tape and write
it on that cinder
block was going to be married by
26 was going to be this going to have
three kids going to be
this was not going to have spent six
years with a convicted child luster
trying to fight the justice
system had a different picture when I
was 38 I want you to carry that center
block around your backyard for a little
while spend some time being really sad
and really angry and really
frustrated
and your shoulders are going to ache
your hands will ache your forearms will
get really tight and
heavy and then after five minutes 20
minutes however long it till it burns I
want you to throw that thing on the
floor on the ground somewhere in the
back corner of your yard or out in a
field somewhere and say I'm never
picking that up
again because choosing to carry that
with you only brings misery into
today it does not solve what didn't
happen at 27 28 31
33 and the question you have to ask
yourself now is what am I going to do
now am I going to stick with this guy
just be married to a convicted felon
forever or in love I am sticking with
okay then you have to own the choices
knowing all the ins and outs yeah great
you have to like I'm choosing to be
single for the rest of my life or I'm
not choosing to be single but but I'm
choosing to not have another intimate
Embrace for the rest of my
life
period I'm not saying it's a bad choice
I just want you to fully own
specifically the choices that you make
I'm never going to have a family around
a Christmas tree that's that's the the
the you know the the the the story book
traditional kind you're G have family
you have your parents you have cousins
you may adopt a kid you may have all
kind of things but I want you to fully
own what that means and I'm not saying
don't make that choice
man but the more you make you stand firm
I'm staying with this
guy and don't acknowledge the cost of
that decision the more you your body
tries to solve for the Gap in the
Declaration I will live in this town in
this house and work this job I will stay
with this convicted child molester
because I know he's innocent okay cool
you get to make that choice and here is
the cost on the other side your body as
Vander culk says keeps the score it
knows that that means we don't have
anybody to keep us warm in the winter
that means we don't ever have anybody to
stroll and just go shopping we don't
have anybody that's going to surprise us
with flowers or ice cream and that's
okay but that's a choice you have to own
and so when you long for God I wish I
just had somebody on the couch watching
this new season of you have to go no no
no I picked him I picked him and this
goes for any relationship man I wish I
just had a wife that wanted to go to
CrossFit with me I picked
her I wish I had a husband so I that
made more money so I could get the new
Tahoe no no no I love him I picked
him start with that letter to your to
your 26y old self tell her you love
her tell her you've ch chosen the life
that you wanted and it's
hard maybe you don't regret it or maybe
you start to keep a cost accounting
sheet on the other side and say all
right if I stay with this guy here's
what's going to cost going cost this and
this and this and this and this and all
these dreams are going to go away that's
cool I'm going to grieve them because I
wanted them but they're not it's not the
life I chose okay but I want you to
begin to take active role in choosing
owning your
life just don't want you to wake up at
58 and what did I do I just let it whole
thing slip through my
fingers and by the way 38 you're just
getting started I'm way older than you
not way Kelly is way older than you I
missed a few years
older and if you make some changes can
all be pretty amazing moving
forward